man am I out of shape
there we go hey Anna Sven where'd you
guys go we totally lost marshmallow back
there
hey we were just talking about you
remember those shelves and shelves of
Disney Classics you used to have on VHS
the spines of their spongy plastic cases
promising adventurers with foxes and
cats lions and bears princesses and
puppets well we went ahead and compiled
a list of every Disney animated film
from the last 30 years and ranked them
the best way we know how by Tomato Meter
since Disney has such a long history
this time around we're only looking at
the films from the last 30 years sorry
The Little Mermaid you barely missed the
cutoff and we're also excluding Pixar
movies and anything without a theatrical
release so meter meter on the wall who's
the freshest of them all let's find out
[Music]
number 10 big hero 6. robotics Prodigy
hero lives in the city of San fransokyo
next to his older brother Tadashi Hiro's
closest companion is Baymax a robot
whose sole purpose is to take care of
people when a devastating turn of events
throws Hiro into the middle of a
dangerous plot he transforms Baymax and
his other Friends Gogo tamago Wasabi
honey lemon and Fred into a band of
high-tech Heroes starring Ryan Potter
and directed by Don Hall and Chris
Williams critics say agreeably
entertaining and brilliantly animated
Big Hero 6 is briskly pace action-packed
and often touching
okay new plan forget the mask take out
the Bots they'll get sucked up into the
portal now that is a plan honey Fred can
you give us some cover like you have to
ask
let's do this Freddy smoke free
[Music]
thank you
ready
[Music]
gravity's getting a little weird here
guys wait let's use this
Fury
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back kick knife hands roundhouse
amethyst
this end now
looks like you're on a microbox
[Music]
number nine Tangled when the Kingdom's
Most Wanted Bandit Flynn Rider hides in
a convenient Tower he immediately
becomes a captive of Rapunzel the
spire's longtime resident crowned with
70 feet of magical golden hair she has
been locked away for years and
desperately wants Freedom The Feisty
teenager strikes a deal with Flynn and
together they begin a whirlwind
Adventure
starring Mandy Moore Zachary Levi and
directed by Nathan breno and Byron
Howard critics say while far from
Disney's greatest film Tangled is a
visually stunning thoroughly
entertaining addition to the Studio's
classic animated Canon
here
[Music]
I waited a long time for this oh
mama I have got to get me one of these
you should know that this is the
strangest thing I've ever done
how about two out of three
[Music]
you should see your faces because you
look
ridiculous number eight Frozen when
their Kingdom becomes Trapped In
Perpetual winter Fearless Anna joins
forces with Mountaineer Kristoff and his
reindeer sidekick to find Anna's sister
Snow Queen Elsa and break her icy spell
although their Epic Journey leads them
to encounters with mystical trolls a
comedic snowman harsh conditions and
magic at every turn Anna and Kristoff
bravely push onward in a race to save
their Kingdom from Winter's cold grip
starring Kristen Bell Adina Menzel
Jonathan Groff Josh gadd and directed by
Chris buck and Jennifer Lee critics say
beautifully animated smartly written and
stuck with sing-along songs Frozen adds
another worthy entry to the Disney Canon
am I right
hi you're creepy
back at you please don't drop me come on
it's just the head no all right we got
off to a bad start
all right
wait what am I looking at right now why
are you hanging off the Earth like a bat
all right wait one second oh
oh thank you you're welcome now I'm
perfect
almost it was like my whole life got
turned upside down oh too hard I'm sorry
are you okay are you kidding me I am
wonderful I've always wanted a nose
[Music]
oh I love it even more all right let's
start this thing over hi everyone I'm
Olaf and I like warm hugs
Olaf
and you are oh
um I'm Anna and who's the funky looking
donkey over there that's fun uh-huh and
who's the reindeer
fan oh oh okay make things easier for me
I'll look at him try to kiss my nose I
like you too number seven Winnie the
Pooh
stories inspired by A.A Milne add up to
a very busy day for Winnie the Pooh and
Friends upon learning that Eeyore has
lost his tail the residents of the
Hundred Acre Woods start a contest to
see who can find a new one for The
Melancholy donkey with the pot of honey
going to the winner amid the goings-on
owl mistakenly relates the news that
Christopher Robin has been abducted
however all ends well when Pooh finds a
land of sweet delights starring Jim
Cummings Craig Ferguson and directed by
Stefan J Anderson and Don Hall critics
say short nostalgic and gently Whimsical
Winnie the Pooh offers young audiences
and their parents a sweetly traditional
family tree there's a very important
thing to do
it's just you Bloon
[Music]
I am the help
how'd you ever get stuck up there
it wasn't the Baba action was it
oh good I knew the back seat wasn't
around here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
number six Lion King this Disney
animated feature follows the adventures
of the Young Lion Simba the heir of his
father Mufasa Simba's Wicked Uncle scar
plots to usurp Mufasa's Throne by luring
father and son into a stampede of
wildebeest but Simba escapes and only
Mufasa is killed Simba returns as an
adult to take back his homeland from
scar with the help of his friends Timon
and Pumbaa starring Matthew Broderick
Jeremy Irons James Earl Jones and
directed by Roger allers and Rob Minkoff
critics say emotionally stirring richly
drawn and beautifully animated The Lion
King is a pride within Disney's Pantheon
of classic family films
look huh
you see
he lives in you
father
Simba
forgotten me no
how could I you have forgotten who you
are and so forgotten me
look inside yourself Simba you are more
the
come
you must take your place in the circle
of life how can I go back
not who I used to be
[Music]
you are my son and the one true king
everybody
no please don't leave me
bother
number five Beauty and the Beast in
arrogant Young Prince and his castle
servants fall under the spell of a
wicked enchantress who turns him into
the Hideous Beast until he learns to
love and be loved in return the spirited
headstrong Village girl Belle enters the
beast's Castle after he imprisons her
father Maurice with the help of his
Enchanted servants including the
matronly Mrs Potts Bell begins to draw
the cold-hearted Beast out of his
isolation
starring Paige O'Hara Robbie Benson and
directed by Gary Truesdale and Kirk wise
critics say enchanting sweepingly
romantic and featuring plenty of
wonderful musical numbers Beauty and the
Beast is one of Disney's most elegant
animated offerings
here now oh don't do that
just hold still
that hurts you'd hold still it wouldn't
hurt as much if you hadn't around way
this wouldn't have happened if you
hadn't frightened me I wouldn't have run
away
well you shouldn't have been in the West
Wing well you should learn to control
your temper
now hold still
This Might Sting a little
by the way
thank you
for saving my life
number four Raya and The Last Dragon
long ago in the fantasy world of
commandra humans and Dragons lived
together in harmony but when Sinister
monsters known as the Drone threaten the
land the dragons sacrificed themselves
to save Humanity now 500 years later
those same monsters have returned and
it's up to a lone Warrior Raya to track
down the last dragon in order to finally
stop the Drone for good however along
her journey she'll learn that it'll take
more than Dragon magic to save the world
it's gonna take trust as well starring
Kelly Marie Tran Aquafina and directed
by Don Hall and Carlos Lopez Estrada
critics say another gorgeously animated
skillfully voiced entry in the Disney
Canon Raya and The Last Dragon continues
the Studio's increased representation
while reaffirming that its classic
formula is just as reliable as ever
[Music]
took took roll
[Music]
s oh what's that girl that's namari
she's the backstabbing Venturi that
broke the world
wow those cats are really fast huh
what do Captain drone have in common
um they have no salt and they both hate
water
number three Aladdin when Street rat
Aladdin frees a genie from a lamp he
finds his wishes granted however he soon
finds that the evil has other plans for
the lamp and for Princess Jasmine but
can Aladdin save Princess Jasmine and
his love for her after she sees that he
isn't quite what he appears to be
starring Scott weinger Robin Williams
Linda Larkin and directed by Ron
Clements and John musker critics say a
highly entertaining entry in Disney's
Renaissance Era Aladdin is beautifully
drawn with near classic songs and a cast
of scene stealing characters Princess
Jasmine you're very wonderful
magnificent glorious punctual punctual
punctual sorry uh beautiful nice
recovery
I'm rich too you know
yeah the daughter of a sultan I know
a fine prize for any Prince to marry uh
right right a prince like me
a prince like you and every other stuff
shirts I've met
[Applause]
just what go jump off a balcony what
okay fine but remember be yourself yeah
right what uh uh you're right
ah you aren't just some price to be one
you should be free to make your own
choice
I'll go now no what what
how
are you doing that
it's a magic carpet
it is lovely
you uh
you don't want to go for a ride do you
we could get out of the palace see the
world is it safe sure do you trust me
what
do you trust me number two Moana an
adventurous teenager sails out on a
daring mission to savor people during
her journey Moana meets the once Mighty
demigod Maui who guides her in her quest
to become a master way finder together
they sail across the open ocean on an
action-packed Voyage encountering
enormous monsters and impossible odds
along the way Moana fulfills the ancient
quest of her ancestors and discovers the
one thing she always sought her own
identity starring AO Lee cravalho Dwayne
Johnson and directed by John musker and
Ron Clements critics say with a title
character as three-dimensional as its
lust animation and a story that adds
fresh depth to Disney's time-tested
formula Moana is truly a family-friendly
adventure for the ages come
on
Maui shapeshifter demigod of the Wind
and Sea I am one hero of men what it's
actually Maui shapeshifter demigoda the
Wind and Sea hero of men I interrupted
from the top hero of men go
I am sorry sorry sorry sorry and women
men and women both oh not a guy girl
thing uh you know Maui is the hero to
all you're doing great
what no I'm here too of course of course
yes yes yes yes now he always has time
for his fans
[Music]
you use a bird to write with
it's called tweeting
I know not every day you get a chance to
meet your hero
you are not my hero and I'm not here so
you can sign my ore I'm here cause you
stole the heart of te fiti and you will
board my boat
still across the sea and put it back
um yeah
it almost sounded like you don't like
meat which is impossible because I got
stuck here for a thousand years trying
to get the heart as a gift for you
Mortals so you could have the power to
create life itself yeah so what I
believe you were trying to say is thank
you thank you you're welcome and before
we reveal number one here are some honor
Hercules
Disney tackles Greek mythology in this
animated feature Hercules a son of Gods
with sinach as a baby by Hades and
forced to live among Mortals as a half
human half God now a teenager Hercules
needs to perform a rite of passage on
Earth to prove himself worthy of living
with the Gods on Mount Olympus with his
Plucky seder sidekick philatitis along
for the ride Hercules must learn how to
use his strength to defeat a series of
evil creatures starring Tate Donovan
Danny DeVito and directed by Ron
Clements and John musker critics say
fast-paced and packed with dozens of Pop
Culture references Hercules might not
measure up with the true Classics of the
Disney Pantheon but it's still plenty of
fun I'll have to ask you to release that
young keep moving Junior lady
but you aren't you a damsel in distress
I'm a damsel I'm in distress I can
handle this have a nice day uh
ma'am I'm afraid you may be too close to
the situation
what are you doing get your sword sword
right right rule number 15 Heroes only
let's go down this weapon
hahaha
he's gotta do it on his own come on kid
concentrate
use your head
oh
all right got big kid not exactly what I
had in mind but not bad
oh Jesus I'm I'm really sorry that was
dumb
Emperor's New Groove
arrogant Young Emperor Cusco is
transformed into a llama by his power
hungry advisor the devious Diva isma
stranded in the jungle cusco's only
chance to get back home and reclaim the
High Life rests with a good-hearted
peasant named Pacha together they must
return Cusco to the throne before isma
tracks him down and finishes him off
starring David Spade John Goodman Eartha
Kitt and directed by Mark dindall
critics say The Emperor's New Groove
isn't the most ambitious animated film
but it's brisk Pace fresh characters and
big laughs make for a great time for the
whole family
me that easily who does that ungrateful
little worm think he is does he a little
to the left
have any idea of who he's dealing with
do this to me why I practically raised
him
okay thank you would have turned out
better yeah go figure well it's better
you're taking that your anchor in these
things instead of the real Cusco huh
I'll get rid of Cusco
the real Cusco
of course the real Cusco
the way and no air to the to the throne
I'll take over the
arms oh how does that work with you
being fired now the only ones who know
about that are three of us soon to be
the two of us and I'm one of those two
right to the secret lab
pull the lever crunk
[Music]
why do we even have that liver
The Princess and the Frog hard-working
and ambitious Tiana dreams of one day
opening the finest restaurant in New
Orleans her dream takes a slight detour
when she meets Prince Naveen who has
been turned into an amphibian by evil Dr
facilier mistaking her for a princess
and hoping to break the spell Naveen
plants a kiss on portiana thereby
turning her into a frog as well the pair
hop along on an adventure to seek the
help of a powerful voodoo priestess
starring Anika Noni Rose Bruno Campos
Keith David and directed by Ron Clements
and John musker critics say the warmth
of traditional Disney Animation makes
this occasionally lightweight fairy tale
update a lively and captivating
confection for the holidays
not believe I'm doing this
please
very funny
so what now
I reckon you want a kiss
ing would be nice yes
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I did not
mean to scare you
you have a very strong iron princess
okay please put the monkey down
please please please
oh wow allow me to introduce myself I am
Prince Naveen
Mulan
people that our ailing father will be
drafted into the Chinese military Mulan
takes his spot though as a girl living
under a patriarchal regime she is
technically unqualified to serve she
cleverly impersonates a man and goes off
to train with fellow recruits
accompanied by her Dragon Mushu she uses
her smarts to help ward off a hunt
Invasion falling in love with a dashing
Captain along the way starring Ming Na
Wen Eddie Murphy BD Wong and directed by
Barry cook and Tony Bancroft critics say
exploring themes of family Duty and
honor Mulan breaks new ground as a
Disney film while still bringing vibrant
animation and sprightly characters to
the screen
way ahead of you sister come on
[Music]
Susan I need Firepower who are you your
worst nightmare
[Applause]
on the roof look
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
it looks like you're out of ideas
not quite and finally number one
zootopia from the largest elephant to
the smallest shrew the city of zootopia
is a mammal Metropolis where various
animals live and Thrive when Judy Hopps
becomes the first rabbit to join the
police force she quickly learns how
tough it is to enforce the law determine
to prove herself Judy jumps at the
opportunity to solve a mysterious case
unfortunately that means working with
Nick Wilde a Wily Fox who makes her job
even harder starring Jennifer Goodwin
Jason Bateman Idris Elba and directed by
Byron Howard and Rich Moore critics say
the brilliantly well-rounded zootopia
offers a thoughtful inclusive message
that's as rich and timely as it
sumptuously state-of-the-art animation
all while remaining fast and funny
enough to keep younger viewers
entertained foreign
you're a conductor now huh Hey listen it
would take a miracle to get this rust
bucket going
well Hallelujah we we kind of got a
situation at the left it just got worse
mission accomplished would it be
premature for me to do a little Victory
too too all right one two two
well I can cross that off the bucket
list
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest TV shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]